donc sarthe qu'il ya pour le moment une
position correcte de nage des enfants
qui jouent le petit système avait que 6
des six mois les amis
un qui commence ce match en avance on a
même pas eu le temps de rentrer dedans
on va voir ce qui fait mythe pour
déstabiliser joueurs français personne
n'est dupe a boy non mais c'était
vraiment écrit 23h40 sur le truc au kef
où gesing cours voilà je pense forêts
russes hard rock rapidement voilà c'est
parfait bon là il fait un bon début
c'est nickel il va mettre la dame ans et
7 lecavalier ans et 6 ou même cavalier
c6 direct donc logé une structure des
quatre c4 c1 et audemars roxy c'est pas
un truc que sarda étudiée mais l'autre
connaît pas non plus faire l'autre mythe
désolé de dire l'autre mais c'est un
terme générique qui est gênante quand on
parle aux échecs on pense à l'adversaire
comme l'autre celui d'en face la deux le
l'ennemi quoi donc il fait damas quatre
dames à quatre ça sert à rien donc ça
déjà c'est une bonne nouvelle et dans
les coûts pourrait jouer sardiha fou 17
qui se fout des êtres humains parce que
ça gagne un temps sur la dame et
cavaliers saisissons développe on gagne
un temps sur le cavalier on food s est
joué savard bouger la dame et cavaliers
c6 voyez ça joue pas très bien la côte
et blanc ça joue pas très bien dame ces
deux cavaliers ses six sorties va
pouvoir développer et développe ses
pièces petit à petit peut y avoir un
jour un vis-à-vis intéressant pourra
regarder dès qu'elle prend 1,4 ou quoi
h6 bon pourquoi pas ça gagne encore un
temps sur le fou s'il fait fouet catia
v5
ça peut tomber fou prend ici supra m6
gagne la paire de fou on fouille 3 bien
joué du coup il se replace la faute
sortir la dernière pièce met une tour
ans et huit en face de la dame et poussé
b5
donc là ça va ça devrait passer
tranquillement cavaliers c6 pour ses 8
on développe s'ils rentrent bien dans sa
partie que le cavaly vient à eux cinq
près d'un game sans prévenir ouais pas à
10 minutes d'avancé un vêtement
là ils jouent très bien sarhadi fait
vraiment sa partie la développer toutes
ces pièces et ça va passer je vous le
dis les amis
pas de panique dame b 3 ça fait aucun
sens les coûts de mythe
là il faut juste un petit peu réfléchir
peut-être dams et 7 pour protéger le
pion et on se ramène sur la colonne sait
et on attaque le pion ces quatre
cavaliers eu 5
voilà c'est c'est très tranquille
est ce qu'il ya un autre coût possible
il ya cavaliers g4 aussi des reins qui
est très intéressant régis dams est pas
ce que l'on voit un pion attaque et on
le défend après carré les g4 savez quand
même la pression ici et ici et ce après
parfois f6 pour taper sur des 4 je pense
objectivement ça va être le meilleur
coup kg 4 lorsque dit l'ordi men pas non
plus 5 mesdames c'est cette c'est
c'était le coup je voulais voir au moins
sa défense est solide et qui a réalisé
quatre ça va arriver tout seul au
prochain pas besoin de forcer un début
de partie vraiment parfait mythe qui
doit absolument sortir le kava lin la
soie en d2 soit en c3 alors il doit
peut-être commencer par h3 pour éviter
cavaliers g4 mais géré dans l'esprit il
doit vraiment penser à sortir ses pièces
avec les blancs effet qu'à et ces trois
là je pense que kg 4 est assez fort ça
une tête de bons coups yakaré lieu cinq
ou six cas une belle tête suivi de
cavaliers 4/4 et lieusaint que ça mais
pression sur le fouet sur le pion pour
l'attaqué deux fois mais qui
plus il peut avoir des dessine co qui
partent avec dame damage de maths ça
peut tellement marché j'espère qu'il le
voit qui est g4 c'est tellement
thématique via cavalia 5 aussi ré
briquet à 5 y gagne peut-être le pion
aux rails en a tellement la grille ya
tellement de bons coups il ya que des
bons coups la cave a lieu cinq heures
elias 5 qui a rédigé 4,5 c'est une
énorme erreur
ça crée une faiblesse en d en d5 et ça
profite d'aucune erreur de l'adversaire
ça c'est vrai
une grosse erreur stratégique alors ça
va à coup tout à fait parce que les
noirs en une bonne position sur quatre
ans et six va faire puis on prend il va
reconsolider tour b8 faut aussi s'il est
peut-être même encore mieux en mieux
j'exagère peut-être mais après un coup
comme carey lieu 2 par exemple il va pas
se passer grand chose on va avec le foie
aussi jouer cavalier à 5 mais c'est
tellement dommage là ils étaient solides
au centre et pouvait taper sur ces cas
de taper sur trois et des quatre en fait
taper sur ceux sur ces trois cases et
avec avec le coup eux 5 qui donne
cavaliers f5 a et c bet e 5 et une
vraiment une grosse faute stratégique
mais bon ça perd pas de matériel mais ça
redonne tout et tous les avantages prix
dilapidé en un seul coup bon allez
est il faut prendre un f5 du coup dévier
le pion m lecavalier ont des 4 et le fou
ans et 6,1 façon ça va pas jouer là
dessus
bref au prize 5 jouer là on prend f5
tempo et l'a peut-être qu'ils aient des
quatrains déjà quand même pour rentrer
et dames c6 éventuellement ouais mais
bon c'est pas facile à il s'est hissé le
premier regard il sait que les pions ils
sont sur noir il est bloqué sur sur case
blanche ici devant et il a du mal à
pousser parce que 4 et à kayes points 4
c contre les deux fois des saints qui a
pu on prend des 5 alors faites faites
gaffe en classement elo de deux mythes
il ya écrit 495 alors c'est son
classement mais ils jouent beaucoup
mieux que ça 8il moi je les estime aux
alentours de 1000 milles sans nom
mieux que sa cavale
5 est peut-être possible mais a dû dame
b6 quand même attention à regarder ça
gagne pas vraiment le pion direct qui
valait à 5 dame b 6 ça peut être un
problème qui fait fou des huit ça c'est
plutôt une bonne idée
il veut recycler son fou sur cette
diagonale par contre il faut s'occuper
du problème fouet trois cavaliers g4 a
pas été joué plus tôt dans la partie
maintenant cavalier g4 marche plus parce
qu'il ya la case des 5 mai son
adversaire qui fait f4 alors f4 je pense
pas que ce soit un grand coup ça vient
pas jouer sur les cases
après il veut échanger ses pions doublet
il peut prendre et faire car il ya eu 5
ça lui donne la case de 5 pour son
cavalier non cavaliers des quatre et un
coup aussi éventuellement mais a calculé
par contre tours 8
très bien aussi un sur puis on prend car
elle les prend et menaçe 4 sur fion
principes et normes et f4 c'était
c'était vraiment un coup à un couac au
tfg
81 kg 4 aussi après quand je commence à
y ait un petit peu de m'adapter un haut
niveau des joueurs et g4 devait être
fort vent numéro de leur dise tk me
prends un f4 et tour ces 8es g4 est
aussi possible mais qu'elle faisait
quand on dit depuis tout à l'heure donc
puis on prend et maintenant cavalier
prend du segment là c'est vraiment
cadeau mythe qui donne la case de 5 aux
cavaliers d'où il va taper sur des trois
c'est katia le fou en ligne de mire ça
fait quand même des grosses fautes côtes
américains à tout prendre 5 c'est
dommage
en milieu de partie un petit conseil
quand il reste encore beaucoup de pièces
sur l'échiquier il vaut mieux mettre ces
pièces mineurs au centre que que les
pièces lourdes cavaliers ou 5 sera neuf
fois sur dix plus forts que tout reprend
en milieu de partie est d'ailleurs là on
voit tout de suite ça tapait de partout
et la tourelle tape déjà depuis la 8ème
rang j'ai donc la tour en fait quand
elle vient au centre elle tape un peu
plus latéralement
alors que un cavalier centrales il va
vraiment vraiment vraiment beaucoup plus
s'améliorer
bon là il fait toujours un alors là il
faut regarder les variantes de type
d'amour prend tout reprend et dames b6
ça il faut regarder si c'était le foot
ce serait parfait là ya peut-être encore
tourin dame prend pions prend fourbe et
si ce genre de choses qui peuvent se
regarder après germans ça marche pas ce
genre de trucs mais bon ça se regarde
quand même
il a joué cavalier g4 maintenant qu'ils
trouvent le bon coup en a un des bons
coups qu'on dont on parlait depuis tout
à l'heure
peut-être pas dans le meilleur tempo
mais il fait quand même très mal bon là
le problème c'est peut-être cavaliers
des 5000 va jamais le voir et c'est vrai
que sur un coup comme food et de il a
peut-être des dames b6 cavaliers f2 et
chaoui mais peut avoir un truc
fantastique
il peut avoir un truc extraordinaire
peut avoir un match comme ça et donc
qui va pas le voir assis le voit merde
pardon désolé
ouais pourquoi c'est un bon coup puisque
ça empêche tous les poulets toutes les
idées avec dame b 6 c'est très bien joué
caïds et 5 très très bons coups il a et
c'est pour ça que ce pion aussi 50 on le
revoit regarder le plus réussi que j'ai
tout de suite dit que c'était mauvais de
l'avancé parce que ça redonne cette
caste des 5 alors qu'il aurait fait
cavalier g4 bien avant pour attaquer le
fou il y aurait jamais eu de problème et
cavaliers des 5 et se fout était est et
était mal placé il a peut-être pu
prendre en c6 intermédiaire il ya papier
points 3 passes cac et prend de cet
échec
donc il a fallu reprendre peut-être du
pion justement pour contrôler jouer le
centre après il aurait joué un coup de
fouet la partie continuer mais mais
évidemment globalement en poussant le
pion le pion eux il a donné la casse des
cinq images
à 500% alors cavaliers à 5,6 genre de
truc très dangereux parce que ça se
lance dans des échanges on se fait
manger à 8 en premier mais bon là ça
semble tenir grâce aux problèmes sur
trois y la fedama 5 alors damas 5
heureusement qu'il ya pas fou mais ici
ça cause de tour prangins d'accord c'est
ça son idée par contre c'est quoi l'idée
sur dame prend bessette est ce que dans
le premier set c'est une fourchette 1
voilà le truc ouais c'est que
alcaide 5t vraiment bien joué
dans le premier set
ces six tours prend b2 ça va pas d'un
premier set je sais pas ce qu'ils jouent
sur dame premier set très honnêtement
j'ai juste parce qu'il faut jouer les
amis je vois pas le coup ça a menacé
deux pièges vois pas comment les défend
bref si l'autre fait dame d'approuver
cette saga mme bonds avoir alors là
c'est gabon s'est complètement gagnant
mais après ça joue un compliqué ils le
voient pas
c'est quand même hein
énorme cadeau en c1 c'est un pion qui
donne une fourchette
ça ça se
facilement il réfléchit à autre chose tu
as tous les coups dangereux pourrait
menacer là c'est pas dangereux l'acela
sais pas si tu vas dans le premier set
en fait tu le joues tempo normalement
ils pensent que c'est un piège prend la
gueule du piège t'attaques deux pièces
non protégés c'est terrible c'est
terrible le cirad sa [ __ ] et réfléchit à
des coûts de cavale m ici je vous sens
car elle il va perdre le fou et 3
abusif si le voit pas c'est incroyable
on espère qu'il est qu'ils aient peur
comment tu joues un tel coup c'est
incroyable cavaliers b6 alors là y'a
plein d'options pour prévoir ses
incroyables ne jamais faire confiance à
votre adversaire
ça c'est un conseil très important
cavalier prend 2,3 donc il va prendre à
incroyable incroyable de ne pas avoir vu
le piège comme quoi avoir un petit et
l'eau ça peut décontenancer les
adversaires parce qu'ils peuvent penser
que ça joue faible alors que ça joue
plus fort mais avoir un gros lots ça
peut aussi faire peur et faire
complètement déjoué mais là c'est très
chaud mais bon on passe on passe proche
de la correctionnelle
là le problème c'est que sur dan d2 qui
est peut-être l'idée il ya toujours eu
deux alors peut-être qu'il faut
commencer par cavalier des quatre pour
aller chercher d'un pro b 7 est
maintenant dam des deux mais bon passons
ça défend j'ai deux mais c'est pour pour
montrer des idées et
mais ici c'est un coup peut-être un coup
un peu bizarre mais qui empêche dame
prend bessette
bon il ya dame c5 aussi pour faire des
découvertes qui sera un coup logique
dams et synchro h1 qui avait allégé 4
pour aller faire un math à l'étouffée
ils me le rendent très jolie je peux
vous montrer
amat à l'étouffée où il reste quasiment
plus de pièces pour les noirs il a fait
cavalier de d4 d'un pro b cette dame d2
c'est vrai que c'est dangereux
je pense que dams et cinq cavaliers g4
et efforts je pense que dams et 5 kg 4
était fort avec cette idée de de maths à
l'étouffée
à voir comment
on joue mythe normalement il doit
prendre 17 après dame c3 est un coup
très décent peut-être même meilleur
mais bon on prend deux baies -celles
c'est quand même le jeu hein c'est un
pion gratuit ça protège le cavalier ça
défend g2 j'imagine dam des deux mains
en attaque le fou mais menacent pas
mates
il reste 2 36% à 2 56 pour mythe on se
rentre dans le money time
allez faut un petit peu accéléré la côte
et sardes s'il le peut s'il en a les
capacités
ça va jouer dans la tête bâle est
normalement dam des deux quand même tu
ramènes toutes tes pièces sur le roi
tout reprend f5 cavaliers c2 ou là là
ils jouent complètement à l'envers sarde
au ces terribles souffrances et de kate
français deux tours prend 1,5
ils jouent complètement à l'envers il
fallait jouer la convergence des luttes
sur le roi et là il part il pas rejoué
belle dame ça sert pas à grand chose
regardez injuste pour vous montrer une
variante possible qui étaient étaient
jouables c'était dam des deux disons
fouet fin pour blinder et protéger tout
reprend un f5 pour menacer des dames f2
qui avale epr en f1 fou h4 et jouer un
deux trois quatre cinq joueurs à 5
pièces contre contre peu de défenseurs
et à l'est convergent et complètement
sur ce roi pour pour éventuellement le
maté mais là il est parti sur cavaliers
c'est d'eux dont il joue juste une
fourchette mais qui marchent pas
vraiment parce qu'après prise prise will
i am fourchette mais tout reprend 1,5
intermédiaire enlève une des deux tours
dame prend 1,5 et un coup de tours
lambda qui va qui va la sauver
alors après c'est pas fini il ya encore
du carré lieu 3 du machin sage ou encore
mai
mais bon c'est quand même un petit peu
dommage alors qu'ils essaient de il a
joué dans 17 alors dame 17 qui n'a
aucune idée il doit penser menacé dame
prend des 8 mai le fou est protégé donc
il peut maintenant jouer cavalier prend
un sarde
ouais bah ouais ça là en chêne mende
erreur chez les deux joueurs mais c'est
le joueur français qui en sort vainqueur
eh oui
mythe qui a craqué haïti midh joue tout
reprend il ya dame prend vingt six mizhu
dame prend des huit ya dame prend des
huit il n'a pas vu le la dame protéger
des deux côtés allez c'est pas encore
tout à fait fini mais bon ça commence à
ressembler à quelque chose on à skype
ronde et 3 aussi maintenant au passage
et matériellement les noirs sont passés
devant aucune minute en plus pur mythe
à la mi temps
mythe qui réfléchit mythe mythique qui
sombre les amis il sera éliminé ce soir
mythe qui a réuni ses sept ont varié à
fou prend ses sept
ouais c'est pas terrible le niveau de
jeu ce n'est pas
et rible les amis c'est là il vient de
donner une tour à une pièce en deux
coups ce coquet et son idée c'est saddam
ses huit échecs croit ge cf6 bon déjà çà
et là mais fuite
ok il ya quand même un piège en vrai en
vrai il ya quand même un piège après tu
es fou procès cette dame c'est 8 fou dès
8 ans mais il ya quand même un piège
ça ce serait marlou fois c'est même pas
son idée en fait rien food et 8
j'ai même pas c'est son idée d'avoir ça
mais un roi h7 f6 g6 et dans ma fuite
c'est très marlou vous prend ses sets
joués sur m6 siaka il prend des trois
oui mais je sais les gars il ya ya ya
moyen de réputés ça devant 10000 fois je
veux dire l'idée qui peut avoir c'est ça
c'est le seul piège en fait c'est le
seul truc que tu peux te prendre parce
que tu as quoi t'as quoi de plus tu as
deux pièces et tu as deux pièces de plus
et l'attaquent
il fait des quatre maintenant et non en
fait il n'a pas d'idée juste h à la mpt
et de marloux bah oui ce que c'est le
seul truc de marloux qui peut y avoir en
fait à quoi réfléchir juste dame prend
qu'il prend des trois fois là c'est
juste fini à plus à penser un avocat est
peut-être que dame prend bécade dame c8
roi h7 f6 du coût d'un b6 et plus safe
hockey est là maintenant cavalier g4 et
tout reprendre termine à dos et g4
j'allais voir ses cinq tours prend 20 et
c'est fini ou cavaliers ces deux pareils
et tout reprendra sur échec
bref deux et puis on prend ces 5
enfin juste ok faut juste pas se prendre
un math du couloir où là c'est pas
possible
la cites escaliers et c'est terminé
ça et ça ça s à aller et ça fait 1 0
ouais c'est cool le fruit est mûr partie
presque parfaite
ouais mais après on sait ce que j'avais
dit à sardent dès que ça va devenir un
peu tactique c'est juste qu'ils voient
rien en fait
mythe ivoiriens en vrai
le parti
mythe il voit juste rien c'est
malheureux pour mythe mais il va falloir
retourner dans le placard terrible les
cas qui tombe de l'arbre exactement dans
la partie la partie est impressionnante
les amis ça suffit ça passe a gagné
coûtait du coup ça doit bien jouer ou
pas non mais ça suffit
dire qu'il a bien joué
c'est abusé mais ça
si ça suffit pour
pour l'emporter ça suffit largement
portez donc
n'hésitez pas allez allez sur
sur 100 live aussi affaire à regarder
les deux en même temps
pour la partie retour devrait bien se
passer moi je vais l'ouvrir sur le
mobile je vais écouter une petite nuit
tu peux vous mettre son ensemble s'ils
prenaient du tout je vous jure qu'il n'y
avait aucun moment où j'étais vraiment
derrière la pollution par contre été
très compliqué quand il a appris le
cavalier la tour et que j'ai pas pris la
tour et que j'ai tunnel sur un truc de
merde avec chez parce que j'ai de finale
c'était chelou mais là oui j'aurais
peut-être pu perdre tout ça sous la
glace ans et en fait je conçois pas un
message de simon plus tard donc est ce
que je fais une grave ou pas je chante
je pense que je vais jouer je veux chill
ma petite stationné sur une fourchette
nul probablement sur les six mâles en
trois tours mais tu as bien gérée à la
loyère lassus arrêts prévus peur qu'il
ait préparé quelque chose
il a l'air de bien jouer dès lors
d'avoir des préparer je pense que sur le
web
ces prépas peu ferme avec vous après
cette terrible comment ils stressent moi
je pense que je serais peut-être c'est
terrible et comment ils surestiment fait
l'attrait majeur est content manager
falloir à partie
du coup elle vous voyez ils surestiment
ils surestiment et surestiment largement
sarde son adversaire pensée prépare
alors que l'ouverture était tellement en
sa faveur mais je ne sais pas c'est
bizarre en fait je pense qu'il serait ce
vraiment parce que quand tu vois des
coûts je pars quand tu as des coups
comme damas quatre dames c2 et dames b3
tu peux pas vraiment dire que c'est une
prépa ça fait aucun sens juste faut pas
stresser un légat en général tant que
vous jouez pas jusqu'à un niveau assez
bon ya pas de prépa ya pas trop
jusqu'à preuve du contraire vous
adversaire joue pas très bien
normalement dans l'ouverture et surtout
ça c'est pas du tout jouer sur
l'ouverture 1 on a vu que les blancs
avaient repris l'avantagé puis que
c'était un setter parti s'est passé pas
l'ouverture qui va qui va qui va
la différence dans ces parties là ça se
voit bien j'ai envie de dire ça se voit
très bien on est un peu plus grand m'a
dit de le mettre en petit mais en fait
je vais le mettre en plus grand en pis
vous ça mérite d'être plus grands noms
après il
en petit mais bon unilatéralement je
vais en plus grand univers de rapetisser
balle et a enlevé en minuscule finale
paraissait pas forcément
mais bon ça mérite ça mérite pas
cars 2
c'est moi qui décide et si grave ou pas
j'ai dit groves aller la grande qui va
partir
allez la gombe tu vas partir les amis
bon allez les gars
sur les gars
si ça va partir en grob ça fait plaisir
la petite gramblat qui à partir non il
sera pas prêt contre la drogue il a vu
l'autre ouverture dans la game 1 et
tweed waziri va pas faire de grubb hélas
la grotte qui va partir et qui va faire
mal non
faire elle va partir il va gagner ici
vous allez voir vous allez voir il va
gagner ici avec la grave
non mais je pourrais mettre sa came sur
sur le stream mais c'est plus marrant
pour vous de regarder les deux stream en
même temps je trouve après pour les
prochains matches vous voulez je vous
mettrais sac à main c'est pas c'est pas
un souci allez dim ou la grotte qui part
voilà
la 5g donnant
le déstresser en plus cela grob mais en
fait je peux vous mettre son sens avec
montel de temps en temps au moins y'a
pas le décalage parce qu'en fait si je
le récupère ya le décalage mais la leçon
n'y aura pas de décalage
ouais mais cavalli m6 s'est fait
défoncer il est pas prêt mythe mi-temps
sueur
voyage 3 c'est déjà free cavaliers et
voilà la freewin et voilà après pas
qu'ils tombent arrestation immédiate
ah bah oui voilà la petite gros bête
la grogne qui est tombé ah oui mais
c'est une ce temps-là grob
mais au meilleur moment elle est sorti
au meilleur moment le doute est instillé
chez les adversaires de sardes auch
les américains ne seront pas quoi
préparer face au champion français qui a
sorti la botte secrète pour la qualif
l'agro badikaha oui une la grotte qui
rapporte 10 cas 8 rigole il sent que
c'est fini a boy son cavalier tons
clairs si grâce il va faire cavalier f3
sarde ou des cas doit le petit coûts
intermédiaires
enfin
avec les coûts intermédiaires mais là il
fait plaisir cela il fait très plaisir
il aurait fallu garder pour la finale
ah bah maintenant il faut se préparer
contre londres et contre la drogue voilà
le problème c'est qu'à cavaliers 3 par
contre pas si vous l'avez vu mes
cavaliers 3c morin à ce niveau là
passe pas un jour sans que vous lisez
cavaliers f3 en fait c'était bien ça
allait mais médée 4 ça perdez tout de
suite mais bon il a fait tomber quatre
échecs ces trois mi-temps sueur la
fossette mitch w1 1000w les amis aux
amis tu peux abandonner
il peut rentrer chez lui imite mutti
mythe va retourner retourne au placard
croit cette grotte sorti au meilleur
moment
c'était sûr que c'était le moment de la
sortir la première partie était
tellement dégueulasse de mythe
c'était obligé que ça gagne aussi
facilement
voilà le prix prend pas le pion aux
sardes bas il faut pas qu'ils choke mais
ces dames net de plus en fait les
commentaires on parle de toi et de la
grotte ah bah oui
abbas est sur un moins
et ah bah oui oh bah daniel daniel en
sueur daniel w
je peux écrire à je peux écrire à dany
tu peux écrire à dany je vais écrire
ni silice aimé ça
je vais le mettre en sueur je vais m en
sueur
on va voir
parlons alors s'il en parle mais bon en
tout cas la grotte qui a frappé et là il
va alors si on prend fou prend enfin
tout est gagnant il ya plus rien à dire
petit relief trois fatou gagne en fait
ah ouais
là c'est terminé oh non qu'est ce qui me
fait sarde [ __ ] fouache 3 frérots
qu'est ce tu me fais développe des
pièces bordel mais non
en mais non c'est complètement aléatoire
ce coup de pnj que nous fait que nous
fait sarbe j'y crois pas les amis au nom
du fourrage trois allers
non mais c'était pour protéger le pion
plus aller bouffe le défonce le g5 fini
le quoi
oh non
non fois
c'est terrible comme coup faut l'achever
là il est au sol il faut taper au sol là
il faut le finir
il joue avec la nourriture mais bien sûr
ils jouent avec la nourriture
fall exterminer est là allez allez mon
sarde ces dames net de plus juste us
orthez pièces du grand roque et tu finis
allégé 5 vous voulez prouve la position
g5 damage 5 est prise h7 c'est fini j'ai
5 c'est très simple échange des pièces
va pas réfléchir et échanger les pièces
tu développes tardive il sait pas faire
ça il veut pas je sais pas pourquoi il
veut jamais échangé des pièces
juste des 5
allez allez
mais non mais non ça joue à l'envers ça
joue à l'envers la dame elle vend ses
deux pour attaquer h7l bien plus loin en
b3 bon ça va et adam net de plus
l'autre à 0 pièces développées il sait
pas vraiment joué il a mis le point
l'aude - ça va mais bon il va prendre
cette part oui mais mon l'autre donne
tout aussi
allez là
tha
de toute façon il ya un tel avantage
matériel il peut vraiment rien arriver
de même de grosses lacunes dans la
convention
ouais je sais pas il suit pas les plombs
scolaire georges us qui a validé deux
développent tadam rock et gagne l'aïe
qui prend 17 tempo d'apprendre et 7
après il ya la pression ici et là on ne
veut pas jouer scolaire mais par
principe en fait mais aux échecs tu es
obligé tu doit échanger les
c'est ta une dame de plus en fait tu
t'en fous enfin là ces dames pièce pions
plus en fait même dame prend 2,8 à un
bon coup en fait
mais bon
france et 8 tours prendre comprend des
cinq vins tous gagnants condé 1500 euros
détruirait s'ils jouent comme ça va se
faire détruire à 1500 jusqu'à 1200 1300
5200 ça peut passer à partir de 1300 ça
peut être très dangereux bon ça va c'est
dommage que l'on est de la partie est
parfait et puis après ça va pas trop
mais en fait même si les dames france et
4 en fait sur est content pour cavaliers
des deux est juste gagner la finale
je penserais plutôt positif mais là
ouais la pression à gérer aussi c'est
justement pour ça que c'est important
d'avoir un jeu scolaire quand on a la
pression
ça permet de de se rattraper sur quelque
chose
est ce que le gong
abrams état prend 1,4 n'y a pas que le
gambit royal à française la carotte
cannes la sicilienne lapierre clal
équine les français 8 voilà en plus
l'adversaire vous vois vraiment rien
donc ça va ça gagne facile mais bon là
lui reste plus de pièces aux pauvres
mythe mi-temps sueur et drake
une personne toi ouais la partie que
j'ai joué contre magnus et beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui regardaient pas que
sur sur mon truc mais après cette halte
là dessus et s'est regardé et puis à ya
beaucoup de gens qui suivaient ou
l'approach s league aussi ça arrive
à m
entre devant 5 10000 20000 trente mille
quarante mille personnes là c'est plus
parce que c'est la question d'habitude
des échecs en fait me trompe
ouais mais bon il peut plus rien faire
l'impression des échecs c'est spécial en
fait c'est une pression spéciales et du
coup c'est plus le fait de de jouer des
choses complexes en fait de pas de pas
avoir un jeu pour se stabiliser qui a
qui rend les partis un peu comme savez
le truc c'est que sar d'issue un peu
avec la pression mais ses adversaires
issues aussi donc ça équilibre
ça va ça équilibre
scarlett je découpe bizarres et des
positions bizarres et du coup ça
équilibre
moi je suis d'un point f 7 h 8 dames et
se termine à dos bon bah voilà c'était
pas c'était pas trop compliquer sa tâche
qui sort le bégon co2 à la spéciale
contre me tue la gueule contre sarde ou
même toit cerveau humain non imposition
actuelle même tu la donnes à karlsson
contre ça c'est impossible il ya plus de
pièces je peux plus rien faire
peut plus jouer
c'est impossible même peut-être mythe
contre carl scène il ya une facilement
avec les blancs donc
rien à faire alors qu'est ce qui nous
dit ce qu'est ce qu'ils disent artistes
en live ça va sim de sarlat de faire
virer quand ils sont suivis sur les
américains viennent de
une ombre en tout cas c'était cool je
vais retourner sur mon live id fais pas
ce que je vais peut-être me faire j'ai
envie de me faire un p'tit tft puis si
ça doit faire un débrief du qu'on le
fera ensemble
donc je vais retourner sur mon live id
fait je vais envoyer un raid en fait
j'ai envie de me faire un p'tit tft
quand même parce que j'ai le temps ça ça
terminé beaucoup plus tôt que je pensais
donc en fait on va avoir le temps que
j'appellerai peut-être sardo six
victoires
victoire sympathique de sarda c'est
facile mais les matchs sérieux vont
commencer les matchs sérieuses vont
commencer
donc je reviens tout de suite les amis
petit débrief avant bah on va voir je
sais je sais pas ça va dépendre de ce
hard mais de façon débrief rapide ya pas
y'a pas grand chose à dire merci d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve je crois c'est
dimanche prochain match de sarm bon il
est déjà qualifié mais les choses
sérieuses